Matthew Perry beat up a future Prime Minister,
got Bruce Willis to take a role on a bet,
and once had his heart stop for five
minutes. After Perry's tragic passing,
here's a look back at the most
fascinating stories from his life.
It's hard to imagine Matthew Perry doing
anything other than making audiences laugh
because he's been doing it for so long. He got
his start guest-starring on shows like "Charles
in Charge" and "Silver Spoons," and a memorable
recurring role on "Growing Pains," and has since
become synonymous with sitcoms. Believe it or not,
though, tennis was his first serious ambition.
Perry had quite a promising tennis career earlier
in life. In his youth, Perry was a highly-ranked
player on the junior circuit in Canada where he
grew up, and had real hopes of turning pro. His
move to Los Angeles changed things and gave him
some perspective. He told Men's Health in 2012.
"Giving up tennis wasn't really
a decision I had to make. I was
a very good tennis player in Ottawa,
Canada — nationally ranked when I was,
like, 13. Then I moved to Los Angeles when
I was 15, and everyone in L.A. just killed
me. [...] I realized I wouldn't be playing
tennis for a living, so I went for acting."
In the 1990s, Matthew Perry wasn't
just one of the biggest stars on TV,
he was one of the biggest actors in
Hollywood, period. He and the rest of
the cast of "Friends" were bigger than just
about anyone, and that meant that everyone
wanted to know who they were dating. Over the
years, a few of Perry's high-profile romances
have been well-chronicled, including his time
dating "Baywatch" star Yasmine Bleeth in 1995.
"Aw, you're just saying that because
you're in love with Yasmine Bleeth."
"How could anyone not be in
love with Yasmine Bleeth?"
He also dated Neve Campbell a few years
later, Lizzy Caplan in the late 2000s,
and had a brief engagement to literary manager
Molly Hurwitz that was broken off in 2020.
What you may not recall are some of his
lesser-known loves, including "The Bold and
the Beautiful" star Maeve Quinlan in 2002,
a very brief romance with "Gilmore Girls"
star Lauren Graham a year later, and volleyball
player Rachel Dunn not long after. But even more
lesser-known are some of the famous women he went
out with that never turned into relationships,
such as an infamous terrible first date with
Cameron Diaz. Perry said in his memoir, "Friends,
Lovers, and the Big Terrible Thing" that they
were set up on a date, which ended when Diaz
accidentally punched Perry in the face after he
told a joke during a game of Pictionary. Whoops!
Once he became a household name on "Friends"
it was another superstar that Perry pursued,
beginning a relationship with superstar
Julia Roberts. As he described to GQ in 2022,
after the publication of his memoir, his
courtship of Roberts was "unbelievably romantic."
As Perry detailed, it all started when
he began chasing Roberts to be a guest
star on "Friends." To his surprise,
the big screen star showed interest,
but only if her part would put her into a
storyline with Perry's Chandler Bing. Flattered,
Perry realized that Roberts might have an interest
in more than just a guest spot. He first tried to
woo her with a traditional bouquet of roses, to
which Perry got an unusual response. She wanted
him to concisely explain quantum physics to
her, and it wasn't a joke. Perry explained:
"The following day, I sent her a paper
all about wave-particle duality and the
uncertainty principle and entanglement,
and only some of it was metaphorical."
They began flirting heavily over fax of all
things, and before long Roberts not only
agreed to guest star, but she and Perry became a
couple before they even shot her guest appearance.
Like many stars and ordinary people alike,
Matthew Perry has had his struggles with
alcohol and drug addiction, which have been
well chronicled. The actor admits that during
production on "Friends," he was rarely sober,
with his substance use so bad that he lived
in rehab during part of the show's run.
"You know, it's been pretty well documented that I
had some problems with alcoholism and addiction."
After years, though, Perry finally
focused on cleaning up his life,
and he spent $9 million to see it through.
More than a dozen surgeries were required
to save Perry's life over the years,
including one that doctors told his
family he almost certainly wouldn't
survive. Against all odds,
Perry came out the other side,
but to keep himself healthy, it cost him
millions of dollars. He wrote in his memoir
"I have been to six thousand AA meetings.
I've been to rehab fifteen times. I've been
in a mental institution, gone to therapy twice
a week for thirty years, been to death's door."
At one point, after his colon ruptured,
Perry's problems were so bad they
left him in a coma. He told People:
"I was put on a thing called an ECMO
machine, which does all the breathing
for your heart and your lungs. That's
called a Hail Mary. No one survives that."
But survive Perry did, and at the time of his
death, he'd been sober for nearly three years.
Few would ever think of Matthew Perry as a brute,
and certainly not the kind of person who
would go on national television telling
stories about how he smacked around the Canadian
Prime Minister. Yet, in 2022, Perry did just that,
though the important context is that they
were in grade school together. Perry told
Jimmy Kimmel in 2017 that he and a friend were
jealous of Justin Trudeau and, well, beat him up.
"We actually beat up Justin Trudeau."
"You know I'm not bragging about this.
This is terrible. I was a stupid kid."
Kimmel pointed out that the incident
occurred when Trudeau's father was
the country's sitting Prime Minister,
though it doesn't sound like Perry got
into any more serious trouble than
your average playground tussler.
As for Trudeau himself, the current
Prime Minister responded playfully,
challenging Perry to a rematch two weeks
after he'd made the remarks on Kimmel,
well-timed for April Fool's Day.
Perry humbly declined a second round.
"Friends" was a show full of big laughs
from every member of the cast. Each had a
unique style of humor, and Matthew
Perry was no exception. But some
in the cast weren't always thrilled with
the jokes they were given in the script,
either feeling they weren't funny or
didn't fit their character. After all,
playing these roles every week for years, the
performers may know their characters better
than anyone. And when Perry wanted a different
joke, his tactic was to sabotage the script.
In her book, "End Credits: How I Broke Up With
Hollywood," series writer Patty Lin talked about
how the likes of Perry, Jennifer Aniston, and
Courtney Cox would ruin jokes written in the
script by intentionally delivering them wrong or
badly. This would often force the crew to look
for a fix, necessitating a rewrite, with the cast
themselves often pitching in ideas for new jokes.
The pushback on what they deemed as
a "bad joke" wasn't always helpful,
though — even if they might have made the show
better — especially to writers like Lin, who said:
"These sessions had a dire,
aggressive quality that lacked all the levity
you'd expect from the making of a sitcom."
Matthew Perry suffered numerous health
crises through the years, which are all well
documented. One of the most horrific occurred
while he was doing another stint in rehab,
and was preparing for surgery for reported stomach
pain, which required a dose of heavy anesthesia.
According to Perry, the drug had actually stopped
his heart for five full minutes. He wrote:
"I was told that some beefy Swiss guy really
didn't want the guy from 'Friends' dying on his
table and did CPR on me for the full five
minutes, beating and pounding my chest."
"I got CPR, and the guy that
saved my life broke eight ribs."
The broken ribs required more physical
rehab. This became a problem for his
next movie because he'd just been cast in a
major role in Adam McKay's "Don't Look Up."
As Perry recounts, he was initially to play
a Republican journalist who shares the screen
with Meryl Streep in a few scenes, and it
was "heartbreaking" to miss out on the role.
For some fans, Matthew Perry was
the heart and soul of "Friends,"
with his signature wisecracks becoming
one of the best things about the series.
"You didn't cry when Bambi's mother died?"
"Yes, it was very sad when the
guy stopped drawing the deer."
Believe it or not, though, Matthew Perry
almost missed out on the chance to join
the series in a leading role, not once
but twice. The first obstacle was that
Perry was already committed to another project
when it came time to audition for the series.
"I was off the market because I had
taken a job on a pilot called "LAX 2194."
The series, a sci-fi comedy co-starring
Kelly Hu and Ryan Stiles, followed a group
of baggage handlers working in the Los Angeles
International Airport in the distant future.
"In which I had to sort out the aliens'
luggage and that was basically the show."
The goofy series pilot thankfully
didn't impress network execs,
with one saying it was "the worst thing
we've ever seen in our lives." Suddenly,
Perry was available to audition, and the
rest is history ... or so many may think.
But the truth is, Chandler — and Phoebe
— were originally intended to be minor
Elizabeth's father Paul, played by
"Die Hard" star Bruce Willis. Even
with the show's history of big-name guest
stars, Willis' appearance was a big deal,
and an even bigger one because he
stuck around for three whole episodes.
"You know they say that still waters
run deep, and I want to swim in yours."
"You talkin' about having sex?"
Apparently, Willis did it because he
lost a bet to Perry. He and Willis met
during production of the film "The
Whole Nine Yards." During filming,
the two actors bonded over their love of
partying between takes, but during their fun,
Willis expressed concerns that the film
was going to flop. Perry disagreed,
and the two made a wager: If the movie was a
hit, Willis had to do a guest spot on "Friends."
Arriving in theaters in February 2000,
"The Whole Nine Yards" was #1 at the
box office en route to a $106 million
haul, more than double its $41 million
budget. Willis got the last laugh, though,
as in addition to three excellent episodes,
Willis took home an Emmy Award for
his performance as Paul Stevens.
With the triumph of "The Whole Nine Yards,"
Matthew Perry had a major movie win,
and with "Friends" coming to an end not long
after, the actor likely saw a path to a new
career on the big screen. First up was a
sequel, "The Whole Ten Yards," reuniting
him with Bruce Willis for another run at box
office gold. But the follow-up was a major bomb,
and it's one that made Perry completely
reassess his career. As he wrote in his memoir:
"That was the moment Hollywood decided to
no longer invite Mr. Perry to be in movies."
Forced to re-evaluate his career, Perry used
the failure of "The Whole Ten Yards" to pivot,
looking for quality roles first and
foremost. One of his next projects was
the Aaron Sorkin-created TV series "Studio
60 on the Sunset Strip," which arrived with
major hype, with many thinking it
was going to be the next big hit.
Famously overshadowed by the similarly-themed
"30 Rock" from Tina Fey, "Studio 60" was
canceled after just one year, but that
didn't stop Perry. Turning to writing,
he created "Mr. Sunshine" in 2011 and "Go
On" in 2012. Neither lasted, but he made
a major comeback on "The Odd Couple" reboot
in 2015, which had a solid three-season run.